I don't understand this is very annoying
oh my god
this is impossible okay I really don't
know what I walked into I walked into a
room and I was told I would have to
solve a puzzle I feel like I'm mildly
competitive I like to consider myself
not the most competitive person but I
think it's because I'm usually the one
who wins really good puzzle I think oh
God
I'm talking to something to watch me
fail actually feels so hard I would say
that I'm pretty renowned for keeping my
cool oh just what I wanted
oh my gosh oh my god this is going on it
or no I'm very easily frustrated
actually but I don't know that I show it
I usually just smile more now I'm scared
and nervous but is it saws it's an
animal all right
nothing's gonna move underneath this yes
otay oh okay
a piece of wood a cross in a square oh
I'm not gonna be able to get this this
is silly
what is this remove the X from the
square by making it into a pair is that
a riddle that comes with a puzzle by
making a pair what the hell oh this is
gonna frustrate me okay so this isn't
supposed to convert ok so there's just
glued this is going to annoy me yeah I
already know this is going to annoy me
okay making it into a pair a pair means
two - what two pieces two pieces this
comes apart yes I definitely know the
easiest way would be to break this
because it doesn't seem that strong I
shouldn't break it as much as him okay
like oh so there's clues was it every
five minutes all right
da Vinci's helicopter is its name's fly
up high to win the game I felt like this
is all designed to make me angry how do
you make this thing fly up high I
supposed to be on drugs or something
that that okay I shouldn't throw it is
that a gets through well throwing it
work I don't understand this is very
annoying okay okay I guess I do get
frustrating I guess I do get frustrated
oh my god this is impossible
okay so making me into a pairs in two
separate pieces which is not a clue
because obviously I need to make this
two separate pieces because it's two
pieces stuck together that's not a clue
don't even connect it from the sides
there's a little bit of an edge there
their third piece of paper like this
last food probably may help spin it fast
in the air gently pull the release what
does that mean I did spin it it's not
even like organ homage to being able to
spin it but that is not helpful
but like what it what would that
possibly do am I being trolled paste
with a spin this thing but like how
would that oh no oh no oh what that's
how it does it
I want to put it back together so I can
figure out what just happened just doing
this like eventually we'll do it I just
broke it and it's still of oh how do you
do this I did this by accident and I
don't understand terrible this is not
fun what I feel awful
I don't understand what this is or what
I just did oh I see now there's a lever
in here that if you spin it fast enough
the lever moves this way and then you
can lift it Wow I feel like I'm lucky I
got it because I'm still struggling to
figure it out even after being told what
to do wow this is I never want to do it
again just want to be done
[Music]